now to the coronavirus hundreds of
hospitals across the country are now
getting their first
shipment of pfizer's covet 19 vaccine
more doses should be available next week
today federal regulators said modernist
vaccine
it appears to be safe and highly
effective a panel of outside experts
will offer its recommendation on
thursday
we're really now starting to see the
light at the end of the tunnel that is
going to ultimately get us through this
but in the meantime we have to adhere to
the public health measures
in order to blunt the acceleration of
these terrible numbers that we hear
monday yesterday the u.s hit more than
300 thousand deaths since the start of
the pandemic
health experts expect those cases and
the numbers of deaths to grow
fueled by holiday travel family
gatherings and a broad failure by many
of us to wear masks and socially
distance
the fda advisory committee that approved
pfizer's vaccine last week as we
mentioned we'll meet again on thursday
to discuss modernist drug
if approved the company could distribute
6 million doses as soon as friday